Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Samira Kwache
L’eau, l’or bleu du XXIᵉ siècle
qui porte et apporte la vie.
Vous êtes-vous jamais demandé
d’où provenait toute l’eau
qui coule à flots de nos robinets ?
Elle vient de nos rivières, de nos lacs,
des nappes phréatiques
Et au quotidien, nous oublions
qu’elle est rare et précieuse.
À l’échelle de notre planète,
l’eau potable, accessible aux hommes
et aux animaux,
représente une tête d’épingle.
Aujourd’hui, d’ores et déjà,
un quart de la population mondiale
n’a pas accès à cette eau potable.
En Inde, chaque année, des centaines
de milliers de personnes meurent
de la pénurie d’eau, de la sécheresse.
Et en 2020, la ville du Cap-Vert,
en Afrique du Sud,
a dû importer de l’eau en bouteille
pour subvenir
aux besoins de sa population.
En 2025, on estime que les deux tiers
de la population mondiale
vivra dans des conditions insalubres,
directement liées
à la qualité de l’eau qui se dégrade.
À l’horizon 2030,
selon le scénario du dérèglement
climatique que nous connaissons,
plus de la moitié de la population vivra
dans des régions à fort stress hydrique.
Ce qui engendre déjà et va accélérer
le déplacement de dizaines,
voire de centaines de millions
de personnes à travers le monde par an.
Bon nombre de conflits sont liés
directement à la rareté de cette ressource
et parce que c’est un facteur
de déstabilisation sociale,
politique et économique,
l’eau est un véritable enjeu de ce siècle,
d’autant plus qu’elle est vivante.
Saviez-vous, qu’elle contient
quelques milliards
de micro-organismes par millilitre ?
Ces organismes microscopiques
sont naturellement présents dans l’eau,
tout comme nos intestins
ont une microflore, l’eau a un microbiome.
Ils sont très divers et variés.
Il y a des bactéries, du phytoplancton,
du zooplancton, des amibes,
des protistes et bien d’autres.
Ils sont capables de produire un arsenal
extraordinaire de molécules chimiques
qui leur permet de s’adapter
à n’importe quelles conditions,
même les plus extrêmes,
comme c’est le cas des cyanobactéries
qui nous offrent une palette
de couleurs extraordinaires
dans les déserts acides de grands
prismatiques dans le parc de Yellowstone.
Ces cyanobactéries,
vous les connaissez déjà,
ce sont les algues bleues.
Elles sont là
depuis plus de 3,5 milliards d’années
et elles sont à l’origine
de l’oxygène sur notre planète
et donc de la vie,
telle que nous la connaissons.
Elles sont capables, donc, de s’adapter
à toutes les conditions
et elles sont même présentes dans
les poils d’ours polaires ou de paresseux.
Malheureusement,
l’augmentation de la population
et des déchets visibles ou invisibles
que nous produisons,
associée aux changements climatiques,
réunissent les conditions idéales
pour qu’elles prolifèrent
de façon imprévisible et erratique.
Il suffit de quelques degrés de plus.
Une exposition à la lumière
plus longue et plus forte
et c’est l’explosion de vie qui sature
et asphyxie les milieux aquatiques,
consommant tout l’oxygène,
détruisant faune et flore.
Au-delà de cet aspect
repoussant et malodorant,
ce phénomène qui est visible
depuis l’espace, empoisonne l’eau.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que certaines cyanobactéries
sont capables de produire des toxines
très puissantes, de type neurotoxines,
qui peuvent même se retrouver
dans les aérosols de l’eau
et qui vont conduire à l’intoxication
humaine, à la mort d’animaux,
de chiens, même d’éléphants
en Afrique l’année dernière.
Ce qui pose des enjeux colossaux,
puisque, aujourd’hui,
il n’existe pas de système
pour alerter de façon précoce
les problématiques de prolifération
de cyanobactéries
sur les captages de points d’eau potable.
Et malgré les traitements,
certaines de ces toxines
se retrouvent à faibles doses
dans les réseaux
de distribution d’eau potable.
Les scientifiques ont démontré
de façon inquiétante
que ces toxines étaient aussi
capables de promouvoir les tumeurs
et d’être très nocives de façon
irréversible à notre système reproducteur.
Donc, vous comprenez qu’il est impératif
de mettre en place
des systèmes de surveillance.
Et c’est le cas, heureusement,
il existe des programmes
mondiaux de surveillance
de ces micro-organismes,
basés soit sur la microscopie,
donc, il s’agit là d’identifier
et de dénombrer toutes les cyanobactéries
ou les microalgues toxiques
dans un échantillon d’eau
par des spécialistes.
Cela prend un certain temps,
quelques jours
et cela ne donne aucune information
sur l’état des cellules.
Est-ce qu’elles sont vivantes,
mortes, dormantes ?
Donc, ça pose un problème.
La deuxième approche,
plus réglementaire,
est de mesurer la quantité
de toxines dans l’eau.
Vous serez d’accord avec moi,
quand on mesure et détecte
des toxines dans l’eau,
Les gens ont donc essayé de trouver
des moyens pour aller plus vite
et ils se sont intéressés
à la mesure de la couleur de l’eau,
qui est directement liée
aux pigments des cellules dans l’eau.
C’est très rapide, quelques minutes.
Malheureusement, ça ne dit pas
quel type de cellule est là
et si elle est toxique ou pas.
Vous l’aurez compris, aujourd’hui,
il n’y a pas de système
d’alerte précoce, fiable et robuste
pour aller anticiper
ces proliférations toxiques dans l’eau
et on est toujours dans un système
de gestion a posteriori des événements.
Pendant ma thèse de doctorat
en biologie cellulaire et moléculaire,
j’ai étudié ces microalgues et
tout au long de mon parcours scientifique,
j’ai tenté de comprendre
pourquoi elles proliféraient.
J’ai créé Microbiens Environnement
pour développer et mettre à disposition
des technologies de rupture
qui permettent d’anticiper
ces problématiques
et d’aider les gestionnaires de l’eau.
Les solutions développées par ma société
et commercialisées sont
des outils moléculaires de laboratoire,
qui vont capturer l’empreinte génétique
des cyanobactéries actives et vivantes
dans les échantillons d’eau.
Et parce que ces biocapteurs
sont très rapides,
on va obtenir les résultats
en quelques heures,
après réception de l’échantillon
jusqu’au rapport des résultats.
Ces biocapteurs, ciblant uniquement
les cellules actives,
on va pouvoir tracer
des tendances de prolifération
et donner une véritable météo
de la qualité de l’eau.
En utilisant des technologies
du XXIᵉ siècle,
on va pouvoir protéger les usagers,
sécuriser les sites
et les activités économiques
qui sont liées pour préserver
cette ressource.
Adopter des technologies du XXIᵉ siècle,
c’est aussi passer de la gestion
à l’anticipation des risques.
Et je pense qu’il est important,
aujourd’hui, que l’on prenne conscience
qu’il faut vraiment protéger
cette ressource en eau
pour préserver la vie
et protéger notre planète.
Je vous remercie.